for Halo game burger or bones perfect it
was most likely to do something I like
it most likely to show up late to
practice
Oh burgers I hope I do everything not to
practice everything everything ever all
the time not everything when I had to
come to your work was I late I know
every wife okay okay
most likely to have a celebrity slide
into their DMS Paul er Burgess again
there are some baby yeah not mean I know
nobody slides that you know slides in a
mind like it is so many Melissa yeah but
that's like she said slides for example
like the human left side a will sing me
well I like you're trying to get yours
oh yeah probably nobody cares about me
most likely to get emotional during
rehearsal oh that would don't think we'd
get promotional and looks like tears it
no no I confusion is that an emotion I
mean it's an order right confusion and
frustration here that both of us both of
you guys most likely to be a
heartbreaker he blames everything on you
know this everyone is on me what part of
my breaking no the emerges for sure most
likely to bring home a stray animal
nothing ice yeah by Jessie know what to
me me give me dogs I've saved do you
know how many 10 million yeah right
decision I just say numbers I don't know
exactly know what in theme of the game
virgins why not the last one most likely
to find a better place to keep that
mirror ball trophy she deserves the
trophy yes more than anybody else do you
feel pressure because absolutely it's
your turn she's finished she finished
second three times and she's been in the
finals more than that yeah so for me
there's a pressure that I've put not she
had to put it on me she doesn't
mentioned it once to me but I know and
so there's a pressure that I put on
myself and she deserves it and no one's
gonna give it to us so we're just
putting in throw me happen taking a day
off in six weeks yeah because she
deserves it she doesn't want an I
deserve
[Music]
[Applause]